on this 322nd day of 15 days to slow the
spread
we have a new proclamation from on high
science has declared through
a science's chosen priest the exalted dr
fauci
that although some people are currently
wearing two masks
at the same time which looks very very
funny
and i would therefore encourage people
to continue doing it dr fauci now says
it's not going to do anything there are
many people who feel
you know if you really want to have an
extra little uh
bit of protection maybe i should put two
masks on there's nothing wrong with that
but there's no data that indicates that
that is going to make a difference and
that's the reason why
the cdc has not changed the
recommendation
so absolutely no evidence whatsoever
that wearing two masks does
anything at all if you want to put the
two masks on your face you can put a
donut on your head too that's fine but
it's
no evidence at all that that would in
any way help
stop the spread of the virus this just
days after dr
dr fauci says it is common sense that
two masks
would help to stop the spread of the
virus a lot of folks
are hearing now about double masking
wearing two masks or
trying to get one of those n95 medical
grade masks
do you believe that that's advisable and
makes a difference
you know it it likely does because i
mean this is a physical
covering to prevent uh droplets and
virus to get in
so if you have a physical covering with
one layer
you put another layer on it just makes
common sense
that it likely would be more effective
and that's the reason why you see people
either double masking or doing a version
of an n95
that was the common sense a few days ago
that is no longer the common sense so
proclaims dr
fauci who you may recall about
seven or eight months ago declared from
from on high channeling the spirit of
science through his
exalted genius brain that you absolutely
should not wear any masks whatsoever
right now in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening really no
closely to this right now people should
not be white there's no reason to be
walking around with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people
think that it is thus
declares science with
geniuses like this making our public
policy
is it any surprise that our country is
coming apart at the seams
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from
bryn mweer who says when robin hood
starts working for the corrupt elite
he ceases to be robin hood that is true
that's true of legendary characters that
is true
of retail investment apps and we have an
update on that by the way
because you've now got two camps on the
robin hood issue
and it doesn't cut evenly across
partisan lines
but either way there is some lie
being told here either way the app is
not
being honest which we will get to in a
second i know
you know if those hedge funds manage to
make it out of
this robin hood fiasco without losing
everything in their major short
positions
they'll have really avoided a very close
shave if you want a very close shave
though you've got to check out harry's
razors
harry's delivers a close and comfortable
shave at a fair price
only two dollars per refill harry's
believes in quality so much that they
bought their own factory in germany
so they could own every step of the
manufacturing process
they source their steel from sweden and
they manufacture their blades in their
world-class blade factory
harry's german factory is one of the
select few manufacturers in the world
that have mastered the technology to
create a gothic arch this is the gold
standard for razer blade grinding 100
quality guarantee
i can tell you i've used many different
razors since i was first shaving as a
young boy
and harry's is the best you just you
just can't beat them
very simple i i uh love their uh starter
set
right now you can get an exclusive offer
on the harris starter set you get a free
body wash for just three dollars at
harry's dot com slash knowles that's
over a 16
value for just three dollars you get the
five blade razor weighted handle
foaming shave gel a travel cover which i
love that to me is like my favorite part
of it
and a travel size body wash it's an
incredibly strong
great deal act fast get yours while
supplies last go to harrys.com
knowles to redeem your offer much safer
way to do it
wonderful way i love it best razor i've
ever used go
check out harry's
justice sam alito a really solid
conservative justice
sam alito just gave a speech to the
federalist society where he described
the coronavirus lockdowns
as a sort of constitutional stress test
this is causing lots of consternation
and lots of people are very angry at
alito for saying this he pointed out
that this constitutional stress test is
placing restrictions
on liberty that were quote previously
unimaginable
he says we have never before seen
restrictions
as severe extensive and
prolonged absolutely true this is true
with regard to
individual liberty this is true with
regard to
many political liberties that we even
have in common you know the
the right of churches to remain open the
the head shop in california can stay
open and sell
dime bags because that's an essential
service but
the churches cannot remain open and
you're seeing this different
individual rights and group rights being
being taken away from people
this is part of why i'm not letting the
blm people off the hook for their riots
certainly not i'm not letting the
capitol hill rioters off the hook first
storming into the capitol with the
bullhorns on or whatever i'm not letting
anybody off the hook for their their bad
behavior during all of this
however just as a descriptive matter
is it any surprise that when you lock
people up
for months and months and months and
months and you throw a whole lot of
people out of work
and you upend the economy in many ways
and you
even beyond all of those questions upend
society by shutting down all the kind of
normal social interactions that we have
canceling thanksgiving and christmas for
goodness sakes is it any wonder
that the country starts to rip apart at
the seams particularly when all of this
is being done at the behest of
technocratic idiots like dr fauci who
contradict themselves
within several days of the guidance that
they're giving
and who repeatedly ignore their own
mandates they have mandates for other
people but they don't follow the
mandates themselves
be it on the masking be it on going out
to dinner like avenues at the michelin
rated restaurant the french laundry
be it chris cuomo who's hanging out in
the hamptons pretending he's locked up
in his home not going outside
did any of these people no it's
it's no wonder at all and i think this
is the broader context
in which you have to understand what
happened with robin hood and gamestop
it's still happening
these redditors are driving up the price
of physical silver right now
why what is this all about
we know that this began because these
people on reddit saw a massive
short position from a hedge fund in
gamestop gamestop in itself doesn't seem
like a very valuable growth company
right it's kind of going the way of
blockbuster and all these other
companies the redditors know that
but they they want to take advantage of
this short position cause a short
squeeze
force the hedge fund guys to buy up the
stock that through these kind of complex
systems
they had already sold and then drive the
price up and then these redders can make
some money but the redditors know they
might lose all their money because this
is so volatile and crazy
this is the furthest thing from a sure
investment you could possibly make
but what they were saying is we would
rather lose money to send a message
than keep dealing in this system they
were kicked off of reddit i believe they
were kicked off of reddit they were
certainly kicked off of discord they
were kicked off of various other social
media platforms
so what did they do they
bought a billboard in times square they
bought a digital billboard in times
square
54th in broadway that said dollar sign
gme that's the
the stock name the ticker name for for
gamestop
gme go burr which is meme language right
it's the sort of internet
jokes that you see about like the money
printer going burr this idea that we're
just going to print money and money and
money and you see brr
is the way to describe that well same
thing with gme because they're saying
it's going to go
all the way up to the moon these guys
know that they could lose money and they
very likely will lose money
uh who paid for that billboard i don't
know but whoever paid for it
definitely gonna lose some money but
they believe that this system
is corrupt and it's hard to conclude
otherwise what happened at robin hood
i want to be as fair to robin hood as i
possibly can and i want to be as fair to
the
financial services industry as we
possibly can some of my best friends
are hedge fund analysts i say that you
know i actually mean that
some of my best friends have worked for
hedge funds and still work for hedge
funds
so i want to be fair to these guys but i
also don't want to just take this kind
of old gop line where we
the gop just like shills for the
financial services industry and says
they can do no wrong
what happened here with robin hood
the the argument that is being made
right now
that robin hood is positioning
themselves to make they published an
op-ed in usa today
and they published a blog post on their
own website this from vlad tanev
the the head of robin hood he says that
the reason
that that all of this happened is
because it's you know they want to put
their customers first they're not
showing for the hedge funds
it's because they needed to put up a lot
of money
uh as a mandated deposit on the on the
investment so
this is in his own words our clearing
house mandated
deposit requirements related to stocks
increased
tenfold in a matter of days so when he's
got when you go and you buy stocks on
robin hood
you the robin hood then has to go to the
clearinghouse
and put deposits down so if the if the
deposits go way way way up and the
investments go way up
then their deposit requirements are
going to go way up they
are what led us to put temporary buying
restrictions in place on a small number
of securities that the clearinghouses
had raised their deposit requirements on
it was not because we wanted to stop
people from buying these or any stocks
we built robinhood to provide access to
investing for all yeah okay fine
he says the same thing in a blog post
he says yeah we we basically just didn't
have the cash to cover up all of these
these investments with our clearinghouse
to put the deposits down to make sure
everything was hunky-dory okay fine
a plausible argument however
this guy seemed to contradict himself
when all of this was going down
on cnbc when he was asked explicitly is
this a liquidity problem is this because
you don't have the cash
to cover these investments he said
absolutely not
it sounds to me though that you're
suggesting that there was a liquidity
problem
inside the firm and my question about
that then raises all sorts of new
questions about whether there's a
systemic
issue uh underneath the system and
underneath the company unto itself
no no there was no liquidity problem and
to be clear
this was done preemptively so we did
this proactively
uh and thousands of other securities
remain tradable on the platform
customers that held these positions
um were able to sell them and we're
doing what we can
to allow buying and to remove these
restrictions in the morning so maybe
this guy just isn't making himself clear
enough maybe
i just don't understand the intricacies
of this
aspect of financial services but it
would seem to me this guy is
contradicting himself
it would seem to me on the one hand he's
saying yeah we didn't have the cash to
cover all these positions so we had to
shut it down
and then on the other end he's saying no
we have plenty of cash cash isn't the
problem everything's great at robin hood
either way
whatever side you come down on i can see
arguments for i can sort of see
arguments for defending robin hood
i mostly see arguments for not defending
them either way we need an investigation
absolutely the baseline take that you
need to have on this is
we need to investigate what happened
here because we're getting conflicting
information
in this case from the same guy talking
about all of these securities and
speaking of security
you have got to protect your house with
ring it is the perfect time
to upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell with ring you can see and
speak to whoever is at the door from
anywhere
right on your phone so you will never
miss a visitor whether it's your
neighbor
your your dinner coming over through the
delivery guy
your groceries maybe your in-laws who
knows who knows you're going to want to
know you're going to have a different
reaction to all of those
you are going to want to know you can do
it from your bedroom you can do it from
your office you can do it from a beach
with motion detection you will get
notified even if the visitor doesn't
ring the doorbell
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know it makes
me feel very safe
knowing that sweet little alisa and
little june my wife and my newborn child
are safe they can know who's at the door
before they open it
especially you know if i'm traveling or
something like that i also love giving
this away
as a housewarming gift because it's very
cool makes my friends safe
best of all it's not very expensive so i
get credit for a great gift i don't have
to spend a lot
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com knowles
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro this is the perfect way
to upgrade your front door and start
your ring experience go to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles highly
recommend it
love ring they've they've been with this
show for a very long time and i'm so
glad that sweet little alisa
can see who is at the door before those
people
enter the house before you open the door
at this point all of these
little seemingly disparate uh political
incidents
i think cannot be separated from
the the feeling that people have across
the parties actually in this country
certainly across the political spectrum
that there is a gap between the people
and the elite
that society is being totally upended
and there's nothing that we can do or
say about it
and it's being upended for months and
months and years and year a year now i
guess
even though we were told it would be 15
days and there's very little that we can
do about it
and as the political system is fraying
anything that conservatives or
republicans do about it
is called evil illiberal authoritarian
nazi
fascist whatever and then when democrats
undertake the same sort of procedures
that is
wonderful that's perfectly acceptable
that's that's a return to normal
right even when the form of the politics
looks the same the the key on this would
be
the executive orders when trump was
signing executive orders this was evil
this was awful this was the worst thing
in the world
and and it is worth pointing out that
when obama was signing executive orders
republicans were complaining about that
too and saying it was
not just complaining about the substance
of the executive orders which i think is
totally legit
but they were also complaining about the
very fact of signing executive orders
saying
that governance through executive orders
is somehow not legitimate
now i've taken a slightly different
approach to this issue
which is i agree i wish that our laws
were being passed by the legislature
but the fact is they're not you most of
the laws that we actually live under in
this country
are being written by bureaucrats in the
executive agencies and given that
political reality
the best way to attack them is through
executive orders right that's the way
you direct the executive agencies
but the the approach to this on the left
and the right the reaction to it
has been totally different you'll notice
listen to this cnn headline tell me if
anything sounds strange to you
biden has signed 42 executive actions
since taking office
here's what each one does
now one thing you might notice about
this is it's not wailing and gnashing
their teeth and saying these are
terrible executive actions and here's
how awful they are right which is what
you would see if trump had done it
but even just the language
executive action that's kind of a new
phrase we haven't heard that very much
in the past but it's bubbling up a lot
now under the under the biden
administration
you see when when trump would sign these
very same things
they were executive orders telling you
what to do forcing it down your that's
order awful bad when biden does it it's
an executive action
action good we want action like an
action hero
oh yeah i like action because joe biden
we all know is so full of energy right
he's so with it he's got a lot of action
in him now biden to his credit is not
using this kind of
uh rhetorical sleight of hand he's
coming out saying yeah i'm signing a
whole lot of executive orders
and here's what they are but today i'm
about to sign two executive orders and
basically the best way to describe them
to undo the damage trump
has done there's nothing new that we're
doing
here other than restoring the affordable
care act
and restoring the medicaid
to the way it was before trump became
president which by fiat
he changed made more inaccessible
more expensive and more difficult for
people to qualify
for either of those two items the
affordable care act
or and the second uh uh
the second order i'm going to be signing
also
changes what the president has done
president of the president
what former president has done and that
a memorandum reversed the my
predecessor's attack on women's health
extreme health access and
as we continue to battle cover 19.
we could spend probably three hours just
talking about that train wreck of an
announcement because there was so much
in there
an apparent freudian slip where biden
referred to trump as the president
what is that what does that say what
does that tell you about joe biden's
mental state and what he
what he thinks about the state of the
country uh then
he goes and says that we've got to help
women's health and we're going to
restore women's health
and that's just a politically correct
euphemism that means abortion
so through executive fiat he's going to
restore
some of the funding for abortion and
some of the access to abortion
that trump took away meanwhile framed
right behind biden is a photo of him
meeting the pope
how how disgusting is this that joe
biden
a putative catholic sitting right next
to a very
intentionally placed photo of him
meeting the pope talks about how he's
going to
restore the butcher of innocent babies
around the country so
one of one of the most genuinely wicked
things i've seen a president
do so casually uh in in my lifetime
and and earlier even you know even even
looking back through history
then biden attacks donald trump
for all of these changes he had made by
fiat he said trump did it by fiat
so i'm gonna i'm gonna restore it
biden is also restoring it by fiat it's
doing the same thing they're both
they both were signing executive orders
it's just that even the procedure of
trump
wreaking these changes through executive
order is illegitimate compared to biden
when biden does it through executive
order totally
hunky-dory it's not even a change what
biden begins by saying is he says look
i'm not there's nothing new here
nothing new here folks i'm just
returning this all back to normal
you see i i had instituted i
with barack obama had instituted the
liberal policy which is obviously
what we should have that's normal in
this country and then trump
this guy had the audacity to get elected
and use the
his constitutionally prescribed
executive orders and you know the very
thing that i'm using right now he had
the audacity to do that and that's wrong
and abnormal and so now when i switch
that back
it's just a return to normalcy nothing
new here of course it is new
when you change the policy of the
previous administration that is
something new but he's saying no what
he's what he's very subtly
saying here is liberal policy is
permissible conservative policy
is not legitimate you used to hear
people would talk about the alt-right
you know look we like conservatives but
the alt-right they're the
they're the bad ones and i guess for a
while there was a distinction the whole
reason that there was the term alt-right
is because some people were saying i we
are an alternative to
more mainstream conservative thought but
now
very quickly that term just painted over
all right wingers
and now it's it's disappeared entirely
you don't hear the term anymore because
what the the left is doing is
delegitimizing the entire right
even the dually elected
center-right president donald trump
who joe biden seems to think is still
the president and maybe a lot of people
think he's still the president
if joe biden said it you come on kick
him off twitter
joe biden is not just signing those
executive orders he also
is signing an executive order to
increase the number of refugees allowed
into the united states by tens of
thousands and very often
these refugees are not exactly refugees
it's just this is just another mechanism
to increase
immigration beyond its already
historically unprecedented levels you
know the the movement into the united
states over the last 60 years is the
largest movement of human beings ever in
the history of the world
and it's certainly the most open
immigration policy that any any nation
on earth has right now
most people according to a harvard
harris poll not too long ago
want to reduce that level of immigration
dramatically
but buy them through executive action
through his executive orders is going to
increase that he's probably going to try
to do it through
legislation as well all of which raises
this question
and and i think people who look at the
trump phenomenon you know how many
people showed up to those rallies how
many people show up to defend this guy
who look at the robin hood phenomenon
how do all the people get together
and beat this hedge fund at their short
position
when they look at the popular opposition
to so many of biden's policies
why can't conservatives
effectively counter joe biden
and the left why
why is we i think we've got
generally the people on our side if not
in raw numbers than at least in terms of
people who actually go out there and are
active and
and vote and protest and
maybe not with mail-in ballots which
makes it easier and maybe not with dead
people voting in
philadelphia or maybe not with election
officials
uh undermining the uh state constitution
of pennsylvania but generally speaking i
think
look we've got we've at least got
roughly half the country why can't we
ever fight the left at all
the reason is because the left is
more or less completely unified behind
the progressive ideology some are more
progressive some are less progressive
but they're all basically on the same
team on the right
that is not true on the right
conservatives just as a matter of our
natural disposition we love to bicker
with each other and pick
fights and all divide all the time and
say it'd be very nitpicky but also there
are just
genuine massive differences
of opinion and purpose on the right and
we're so divided
we cannot unite and
some of the more subversive elements on
the right have
just been caught with their pants down
so we might we might have to
divide a little bit more before we can
unite but we'll get to that
in one second you know earlier this
month we released our first movie
run hide fight this was exclusively for
daily wire members
uh the movie is a really terrific film
the audience seems to love it the
audience scoring rotten tomatoes is
through the roof the critics
hate this movie they hate it not even
because it's some kind of conservative
propaganda piece it's not
it's just not politically correct so the
critics gave it like a negative 5
thousand on rotten tomatoes
i don't even know you could have
negative five thousand percent uh the
audience gave it
something ninety three it's definitely
ninety plus uh you can head on over to
dailywire.com
you can go to our mobile app you can go
to our streaming apps on apple tv and
roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf
to get 25 off that is rhf for 25
off head to dailywire.com we'll be right
back with a lot more
the right has always been somewhat
splintered when william f buckley jr
helped to form the in many ways founded
the post-war conservative movement
he united three groups the traditional
conservatives and the
and the religious right also they're not
they're not identical but
sort of similar the economic
libertarians
and the foreign policy hawks many of
whom were democrats
and those three groups didn't have a
whole lot in common but they all opposed
the soviet union the traditional
and religious conservatives opposed the
soviet union because
of the state-mandated atheism the
economic
libertarians opposed the soviet union
because of the
economic collectivism and the foreign
policy hawks opposed the soviet union
because of their imperial ambitions and
they all came together they had this
common enemy and it was
actually quite effective after the fall
of the berlin wall this
movement stopped being totally coherent
the right didn't exactly know what it
was fighting for you had kind of the
confusion of the 1990s
and the 2000s what are we about what are
we for some people on the right are
these wilsonian internationalists in
foreign policy
who want to adventure all around the
globe and never saw a middle eastern
country they didn't want to bomb
some people are sort of isolationists
you think of the ron paul wing of the
right
they they don't want to go to war
basically for any reason whatsoever
how on earth are those two groups on the
same side you had these kind of
libertarians
and i don't actually don't even think
that phrase is fair to libertarians you
had kind of a more libertine element of
the
right pg o'rourke joked about this group
in a very famous essay called
republican party reptile how to drive
fast on drugs while getting your wing
wang squeezed and not spill your drink i
believe that was the title of the essay
kind of joking about this actual
phenomenon on the right this kind of
wolf of wall street you know go out
there and
totally violate the moral order but
we're all about making money and you
know keeping the gdp going up or
something right
so you have that element and then you
have the traditional guys on the right
who you know show up to latin mass with
their 13 children
and they're all buttoned up and they're
all very proper how do those two
elements work together
uh you have the neoconservatives who
were kind of liberals who got mugged by
reality i think that was the word of
irving crystal you had now you have the
populists you have all these different
groups
the most most loathsome among any group
that even pretends to call itself right
wing
is the lincoln project you know the
lincoln project that these guys were
funded by left-wing billionaires
and their whole purpose is to go out and
say we're conservatives and republicans
but we hate trump you know and we
also hate senate republicans and we also
hate house republicans and we only work
for democrats now
and they milk democratic donors for
money
and they get themselves fancy houses and
pay off their debts
well they they have just um hit a snag
and i i wasn't going to bring up this
story
because it involved someone named john
weaver john weaver
is a former mccain top strategist a
former top strategist
to john kasich he's been around gop
politics for a while he worked for
democrats for a little bit too
and now he's obviously working for
democrats again but uh but
generally he's known as a sort of
liberal republican
i wasn't going to mention this story
when it first broke
before it had really been thoroughly
investigated in public
because i coincidentally happened to
have briefly been on a campaign with
john weaver i don't know him
very well and it's not like we were
bosom buddies or anything but i just
felt okay you know i'm
i'm not going to start taking snipes
even at former republicans
until the story is really fleshed out
now the story is fleshed out and we got
to talk about it
ryan gerdusky broke this story great uh
very tough-minded young conservative
journalist
and uh and thinker and writer jordusky
breaks the story that john weaver
had been messaging young boys
and young men but even people as young
as like 14 years old
on the internet and sort of grooming
them and
things were becoming sexually explicit
and he
was kind of dangling poor choice of verb
he was offering kind of political
opportunities
in exchange for sexual
activity 21 men have since come out
and said that weaver did this to them
nobody wanted to cover this story
gerdusky basically single-handedly
forced the story on people
when he started to break the story all
the news outlets kind of played defense
for weaver
the lincoln project remained completely
mum about it they were just hoping the
thing would blow over
john weaver came out and made the the
kevin spacey defense
he came out and said look i'm a deeply
closeted gay man but i'm now i'm gonna
i'm i'm a gay guy and please don't look
into any of the details about what just
happened
the lincoln project styles itself the
principled conservatives they are so
much more principled than donald trump
who's unprincipled and
all the conservatives who support him
they're unprincipled fascists terrible
authoritarian illiberal whatever you
know
nobody is less principled than the
lincoln project
they finally have to acknowledge this
when the new york times picked up the
story after ryan had done all of this
good work finally the new york times
picks it up and now the lincoln project
pretends to just learn about it
they have this put out this press
release because they're so they're so
disloyal even they don't even have the
integrity
to defend their guy whose actions it
would seem they knew about for quite
some time
they don't even have that integrity they
say it's deplorable what he did it's
awful he's odious he lived a double life
people knew these rumors were going on
about weaver for a long time
they they worked with him they obviously
knew about it steve schmidt
who's another ex-republican one of these
guys whose whole job is to
go on liberal outlets and talk about how
terrible republicans are
he made his whole career and all of his
money off of republicans and then the
minute that dried up
he goes and dances for the liberals
according to the new york times steve
schmidt co-founder of the group said its
leaders had learned last summer from
social media posts that mr weaver who
has a wife and two children
might be involved in relationships with
men but emphasized there was no
awareness or
insinuations of any type of
inappropriate behavior
when we became aware of the chatter at
the time
pause hold on for a second there steve
schmidt is saying
that his close business partner someone
he's known for a very long time
john weaver who has a wife and two
children
was cheating on his wife with dudes
but that was not inappropriate behavior
he's saying look yeah we knew he was
cheating on his wife with dudes
oh but we didn't we didn't think he was
doing anything inappropriate
what does that say about your moral
compass steve schmidt what does that say
about your moral compass
project lincoln
obviously obviously it's just
a bunch of preening and nonsense these
are the sort of guys who say country
over party another meaningless phrase
you join a political party because you
think it'll help your country
to say there's some dichotomy between
country and party it doesn't make any
sense
it's just sanctimony it is a grift i try
not to use that word because it's
overused in politics
this thing is a grift these
rick wilson one of the founders of the
lincoln project is as
is as foul-mouthed and vicious as
anybody far more so he makes trump look
like a boy scout
and he's got photos of himself waving
the confederate flag around
he's not holding it up i think the
confederate flag is on his cooler while
he's tossing back brewski's
now he's going to say oh the illiberal
awful conservatives
they've abandoned their principles
these guys are are essentially the least
principled people in politics
it's funny because i i didn't want to
mention the weaver story because it's
just it's very sad it's very sad for his
family
i you know if it's already out there i
didn't feel i needed to pile on
in many ways i feel i'm sort of
defending weaver against the rest of the
lincoln project here
because weaver whatever he did weaver
has done some really really really shady
things in politics
some things that i learned out actually
that he'd even done to groups that i was
involved with
after the fact but
these guys are no better steve schmidt
rick wilson these guys are no better
if we are going to have a united the
other reason i bring this up
not just to dunk on the lincoln project
which is a fun thing to do not just to
go after squishy republicans who dance
for liberals for a living
but it's because the reason we can't
fight the biden administration right now
is because we're not united but the
reason we're not united is because
in large part of people like this in
part it's because conservatives have
this disposition to nitpick and be
contrarian but in part it's because
there are genuinely subversive elements
that have
absolutely nothing to do with the
conservative movement broadly
which do not share our aims which do not
share our vision of the country
and they need to be excised from
the conservative movement or from the
american right
very few people would consider the
lincoln project to be right-wing
at least among conservatives today but
among
liberals it is considered right-wing and
some of us i think
cotton to that sort of thing we give
quarter to it
we shouldn't there's more in fighting
even among elected officials
right now matt gates who is generally
speaking quite a talented
congressman matt gates is uh going after
liz cheney liz cheney is
the chairman of the republican caucus
it's
technically a leadership position in the
house but it's not a very important one
liz cheney though voted to impeach
donald trump liz cheney supports the
impeachment of trump
very much at odds with her caucus very
much at odds with her party
and matt gates flew to wyoming to attack
liz cheney take a listen
i love wyoming
i think if liz chaney had a rally with
all of her supporters
they could likely meet inside one of the
elevators in the capitol
and still have plenty of room for social
distancing
i want to thank representative ocean
andrew
he's first day as a state representative
was yesterday
and he invited me to be here with all of
you today
i'd say that's a pretty good start for
the young
oh man confess to you this is my first
time
in wyoming i've been here for about an
hour and i feel like i already know the
place a lot better
than your misguided representative liz
joney
pretty rough attacks now i know that a
lot of people in washington
a lot of washington republicans they say
come on stop it stop the infighting stop
the infighting
and this is this is where conservatives
need to be very
focused we need to be very precise
do we really want to kick out of the
party
liz cheney and people like liz cheney
people who maybe they're more like bush
republicans
maybe they're more like cheney
republicans i don't know maybe they're
more kind of more
foreign policyhawks i don't know more
liberal republicans generally speaking
do we want to completely kick them out
of the party i think that would be crazy
you wouldn't wouldn't have enough people
you wouldn't you'd
lose more people than i think those of
us on the conservative side would be
willing to admit
now many people on the liberal side want
to kick out people like matt gates
or they want to kick out people like
josh holy or they want to kick out
people like ted cruz or they want to
who don't even all agree with one
another but they all represent
sort of less liberal elements do we want
to kick those out no we can't do it if
we
do we want a new patriot party that was
another suggestion should there be a new
third party no if we had a patriot party
you just give all the elections to
democrats
however you can't let this kind of
division just fester and faster and
faster
so it would seem to me perfectly
reasonable that liz cheney should not
serve in republican leadership
i don't think she should be kicked out
of the house of representatives i don't
think she should be kicked out of the
republican party
but her position on a very very
important issue
the historic unprecedented second
impeachment of the ex-president
her position on that is
it's too serious it's too it's two at
odds with the party
she cannot make a credible claim to be
leading the party
so she should return to be rank and file
and maybe and and she should still have
her rights to you know
be exercised within the caucus and
within the party but
the conservatives are not going to
effectively counter the biden
administration
if we have leadership that opposes the
conservative base
it's just not going to happen
you know matt gates talked about in this
same speech
he he talked about something i'd never
heard about before
but it's an interesting lens through
which to view all of this stuff the
opposition to fouchy the robin hood
stuff the infighting on the gop
he called it prairie populism my
grandfather was a small town mayor
in not too distant north dakota he
passed before his time
but not before passing into legend and
he passed along a little wisdom
to my dad my old man calls it
prairie populism do right by your people
never sell out fight their dislikes
and never never let the powerful run
over the weak
inspire people through courage
and tell the truth
the truth is that the establishment
in both political parties have teamed up
to screw our fellow americans for
generations
i know that there are many republicans
and conservatives that get
they get shivers when they hear this
word populism
this is happening this
is something that the american people
are sensing
and they are sensing it for good reason
they are sensing that there is something
very corrupt about this establishment
are we really to believe that the
educational establishment is totally
corrupt the administrative state is
totally corrupt hollywood is totally
corrupt but
the big tech totally corrupt but
the financial establishment is like
totally fine 100 totally fine
no foreign policy establishment total no
of course not
there is something happening here
senator cruz talks about this as
the republican party becoming the party
of pittsburgh and the democrats becoming
the party of paris
it's a very nice political formulation
of that for most of my life republicans
have appeared to be the party of
plutocrats now they are the party of the
people
some people are not adjusting well to
that if the republican party is to have
an effective governing coalition an
elected coalition moving forward
they have to be able to make that claim
it's why the left is so
focused on burying these guys who dare
question the establishment and who dare
invoke the language
of populism speaking of
republican division president trump's
legal team
has collapsed so his lawyers have left
we are now being told that it is a
mutual separation the lawyers wanted to
leave and trump wanted them to leave too
this ahead of his impeachment trial you
know earlier i said that trump was
impeached after
after he left office that's not
not quite right i mean that's not that's
not precise
in that he was impeached while he was in
office but then he left because they
impeached him days before he was leaving
office
now the trial is going to be of an
ex-president so is it an impeachment of
a president or impeachment of an
ex-president it would seem if the
if the question of conviction is going
to be after he's left office it's the
impeachment of
an ex-president which is
constitutionally absurd
chief justice not presiding so it's
probably by the by the letter of the
constitution not even an actual
impeachment trial
and this is why i'm not too worried
about trump losing his lawyers
you know he'll get new lawyers it i
think he already has new lawyers
uh it it might upset whatever arguments
the other guys were presenting
might have been a missed opportunity but
the impeachment itself
is a joke you have on the record
enough senators saying this is
completely absurd that
barring some totally unforeseen event
trump wouldn't be convicted
so who cares they could go there the
trump legal team could go there and read
read dr seuss probably wouldn't change
anybody's views
certainly not enough people to convict
the president
even that though even the continued
fighting over
donald trump and the person of donald
trump i guess it has to do with these
divisions that are going on within the
gop
we need to be very very careful here in
this moment
we need to we need to avoid papering
over differences
that are substantive right and just
pretending that we can all go along to
get along and the only thing we can
agree on is cutting taxes but
that's fine we'll put the other stuff
for another day that has not served us
very well for the past 20 years
likewise we can't be so vicious that
we we just divide ourselves uh
so that we're we're each simply a party
of one and we can't get together and do
anything in politics
i remember i forget who told me this but
there was he was describing the
difference between
bill clinton and rudy giuliani this was
years ago
they said bill clinton is the kind of
politician who could go into a room
with a hundred people who disagree with
him and each other
and he could find the one point of
agreement
with each of them yeah you lack cigars
me too
huh you know maybe not that maybe even
more substantive than that
rudy giuliani is the opposite kind of
politician he could go into a room with
a hundred people who agree with him and
each other and he would find the one
area of disagreement
and i think this gets to the difference
between the liberal and the conservative
disposition
conservatives especially in this culture
we're just by nature sort of contrarian
and we all we want to do is talk about
our differences the differences between
the libertarians and the traditional
conservatives and the neocons and this
and that and this and that
we can't do anything together
in politics if we refuse to ally with
one another
now i think one key aspect to uniting
conservatives moving forward is we've
got to just stop
focusing on rather we've got to stop
focusing on
the formal aspect of politics to the
exclusion of the substance
and what i mean by that is we've got to
stop putting a hundred percent of our
focus
on free speech you know bumper sticker
slogan free speech and we've got to
start talking about what we want to say
we've got to stop talking about 100 of
the time bumper sticker slogan religious
liberty
we've got to start talking about what we
believe there was an excellent
excellent op-ed in the wall street
journal today by ryan t
anderson who was for a long time at
heritage foundation now he's
leading the ethics and public policy
institute it's called religious liberty
isn't enough religious liberty isn't
enough
cultural conservatives also need to
defend our views which are
scientifically sound and popular
i've talked about this before i think
conservatives really only the last
15 or 20 years have have
started to believe these shallow bumper
sticker slogans which in the past
conservatives did not believe
so we believe that free speech in the
american tradition
means you can say absolutely whatever
you want to say at all times and we
should encourage all manner of speech
conservatives have never believed that
first of all it's never been true
there have always been broad swaths of
speech that are not permitted namely
threats sedition fighting words
fraud obscenity all these sorts of
things conservatives were never the ones
saying we need to get rid of all
barriers to speech
because we know that standards must
exist this is a limited world we have
limited language
we if we do have a certain speech regime
we're not going to have a different one
this is even clearer with religious
liberty right now in public schools in
new york
in certain public schools students are
taught
that boys can shoot and when girls can
choose their own gender
and there's no such thing as immutable
biological sex
four and five-year-olds are being taught
this the trouble with that if you want
to protect that view
under i guess religious liberty because
that religion is called gnostic dualism
if you want to protect that view you are
necessarily excluding the traditional
view the christian view the jewish view
the muslim view
that there is such a thing as men and
women and men can't become women and
women can't become men
you can't simultaneously protect both
views
you have to choose one
if if a little child in school is going
to get in trouble for saying that sally
can't become steve
then he can't practice christianity
openly
or judaism or islam we need
to we need to come out
and defend certain views that requires
doing the work that we've basically been
putting off since the end of the cold
war
and really maybe you could say been
putting off for much longer before that
which is figuring out what we stand for
from 1945 until the fall of the berlin
wall we stood for opposing
communism right and various sort of
political ideas
fell downstream from that afterward what
did we stand for it just was totally
unclear in the 90s and the 2000s
now that trump has really accelerated
that debate because he does stand for
certain things
right he's willing to go out on a limb
and say no we need less immigration now
we need
to protect american industry we need it
was really ripping up some of the old
kind of orthodoxies that had ossified
over time
what do we stand for
we can't just bury our heads in the sand
the country will continue to rip apart
at the seams if we do that
we've got to answer that that takes
courage which is the prerequisite for
all the other virtues we have to
acknowledge that there is such a thing
as virtue
can we do it or are we just destined to
descend
into more and more decadence i guess
we'll find out i'm michael knows this
the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show